I'd like to formally ask you
to be the next chief executive
of this company.
(SOFTLY) Yes.
-♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
-(CROWD CLAMORING)
To fight this takeover,
we keep close.
The whole family.
I saw their plan,
and my dad's plan was better.
I swear to God, Dad,
if you bring him back,
I am walking...
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
...back to my office,
to... sulk.
-♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
-We're going for Pierce.
SHIV ROY: Buying PGN?
-Who told you?
-Am I not supposed to know?
There are no rules.
-Ow! Security!
-Back off!
This is executive-level
business!
You saw what your dad did
to Kendall.
He could do the same to you.
Rhea Jarrell.
And you must be Oedipus Roy.
The Pierce family knows
what you're after,
and they're not interested.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
-Twenty-one billion dollars.
-Dad.
-What? I'm a mere conduit.
-22 billion.
Is he allowed
to just say numbers?
Twenty-four.
And they can trust me.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪